welcome to this video playing tom
delonge tom delonge something like that
from Sweden and we have two giants
defense one of the real ancient openings
pleasure home for check played for ages
he's playing an interesting line that
scrubbing another pawn I really don't
believe in it to be honest for white I
in fact even had this in tournament game
short while ago and i get i got the
really overwhelming attack with this but
them still let's let's check I can play
I can take and play rugby form
switchover or plain 95 this is actually
the the biggest issue for lucky in this
type of position you have so many so
many interesting ideas that you can
easily get confused and choose some a
sub-optimal line let's see f5 he's got
the check this is a bit a bit worrisome
don't want want that
let's see yeah I wonder body in form and
and Bishop a six this type of stuff come
on let's let's get head
ok so Bishop a6 preventing castles
he's got Bishop h6 though yeah I suspect
that this is not full compensation but
okay it's it's difficult I mean time but
it's also three points three points is
quite substantial of course
so how to how to open up the position
for them mmm well I really expect bishop
age six to be played I'm not quite sure
what my response is probably bishops III
Wow amazing you can really weaken
yourself even more yeah maybe maybe I
have a hard time believing it but ok
let's see yellow a long castles
obviously obviously on the horizon yeah
maybe I should should take the chance
and take you for yeah ok let's do it
like a queen takes rupee a twinning of
the Queen knight takes Bishop a one
winning the rook and he still cannot
castle which is very important of course
the our black has enormous activity but
I'm pretty I'm pretty unsure that them
that is enough or was enough now black
is I think in very good shape but before
I'm not sure it's incredibly difficult
to to defend this type of this type of
position where everything sir attacking
okay this is interesting can take f2
hmm probably this is also what I should
do
ok just take d one on each one mmm YUM
come take it Queen a five
okay activate activate the rook
mmm how do i how do I continue its it's
not it's not winning already or
something it's a I made lots of progress
of course but it doesn't feel like I'm
winning instantly if he plays night if
form i wonder if i can take take Bishop
d3 and then look this looks very
powerful actually and this also also
like
okay if I take it on c4 play Queen d3
intending yeah oh come on if this is not
winning and not much I can do about it I
need to open the position up using the
rooks Roxy voice is a big threat until
this is also check check quite
convincing I hope
yeah but he's got King a one he actually
can go to a one hmm hmm maybe I should
have played the other one I had another
good good continuation okay if I go here
quindi form
now it's got queen deform the only move
but it seems sufficient
under Queen c3 I don't see em a tactic I
don't see a tactical win
I'm below
yeah I really spoiled that there was
certainly certainly a win
I didn't even see the moon that sympathy
that he can actually keep keep the pawn
what a game
check
all very strange
check time warning check
yeah well he's just blundering whatever
check check
check check check check check check
check check yeah I think I'll manage I
have two maid who check checkmate Wow
boom yeah well this was the game with so
many ups and downs um yeah I'm really
curious I mean isn't this winning come
on yeah it is I'm just I'm just just a
[ __ ] this is the problem yeah check
this is in fact it's also winning just
not this is just yeah I need to take
here and Roxy to justice I mean I saw
the move but i thought well rugby aid
isn't this a mate no it isn't he's
writing to me embarrassing i could win
very easy if i wanted yeah well this is
right I also could have one very easily
if I wanted I mean I wanted but I am I
didn't I didn't play the right move I
mean other than that I think it was so
it was pretty pretty convincing after
this point I mean after that I'm just
I'm just playing forever just just
fighting chak dhoom you just played a
very strange it's very strange stuff
here on the queenside and do check just
giving giving away the shack
the night basically and now he doesn't
even get to g7 I mean the the opening
here this was this wasn't fact
interesting it's really a lots of lots
of material here f5 is a strong move
interesting it takes Bishop f6c ha Wow
yeah this looks very very strong yeah
the bishop is preventing any checks this
is hanging and if you play Bishop b2
check yeah well this is just just
tremendous crossfire of all pieces very
strong yeah f5 didn't didn't cross my
mind and tiie I've got 94 e 5 is
probably what he needs to do and now I
now blackest is just winning in this
position and they made it what it was
perfectly all right I just need to oh
this is this is instruction check check
yeah this is even stronger all right but
at least the tense game thanks for
watching